[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to how to
Hollywood I'm your host Kristen Gill and
today I clearly have a special guest
miss Arianna Maddox from Vanderpump
rules this is it hi we ever here today
to talk all things make up she's giving
us an exclusive look into her makeup bag
and also her collab with Frankie rose
cosmetics yes out and available yeah
we're gonna swatch the heck out of it so
let me see what's first in your bag like
what is something that you're obsessed
with um so a lot of people ask me about
brows and I'm obsessed with this
Anastasia
tinted brow gel I use the colored
chocolate which seems like maybe it'd be
too dark yeah but when I try to use brow
products that are made for blondes it's
too light I like a strong ground so it's
basically almost like mascara for your
brows and it helps to I like to brush my
brows up okay um and so I brush them up
with that and then any little holes I
might fill in but powder or with the
powder okay but this is like mainly I
only have this on right now and though
yeah yeah this is like my favorite thing
for brows and yeah where do you get your
brows done because I don't I plucked my
own okay
I actually have Anastasia sells a brow
to go kit and there are templates like
little stencils have those - yeah yeah
so sometimes if I'm feeling like the
shape is getting a little wonky I'll
pull out the stencil and kind of just on
and kind of see where yeah and then I'll
pluck if something is like off do you
trim oh no I don't trim that my gosh
yeah I just pluck like you know I'll get
rid of my unibrow I know what got my
unibrow when I pluck out you know
anything that comes down here yeah and
then I used this and some as a powder to
just extend the ends a little bit a
little bit yeah yeah it works I think it
works pretty well as long as you know
too that there's that rule of like here
in here and then who stay in there
you're good I mean back in the day I had
actually my brows look like actual sperm
so
I feel like my brows have come a long
way the thin brown stuff on my god
yeah people shaved their browsing back
then yeah no Brittany told me that she
literally shaved her brows aha it's like
a stream I'd rather have the sperm
browse then change oh well okay I see
this product everywhere I don't know
about you guys and I've always wondered
like everyone does the elixir on their
face and it like drips down yeah is it
everything what is this so I was the
same I saw it on Instagram and I thought
like what is this that every way all
these people doing their the tutorial
let's have it
I'll show you guys that's maybe you've
seen on Instagram that's the gold flakes
all around the edge mm-hmm so it's like
oil but there's gold flakes in it and
what I do is I put like two like two
drops on my lips as I'm doing my face
makeup so by the end of the top end of
that my lips are really moisturizing or
when I put lipstick on yeah if my face
is feeling really dry instead of getting
my Beauty Blender wet with water
I might dab like a couple drops on the
top to mix with my into my foundation if
my skin is having like a really drive
away yeah yeah or what I've done a
couple times actually kind of recently
discovered this use for it is if like I
get off a plane or something oh this
area I'll just do a little drop and I'll
just go under the eye with it just to
kind of remoisturize that tip radius
notes down because she's skincare lover
right here some of her secrets people
I'm skincare obsessed so yeah yeah yeah
this is what I go through in a regular
basis yeah you were telling me
off-camera speaking of skincare that you
might want to start your own skin
yeah my my might wanna get into the skin
carapace one of these days it's
something that you know I I did a
collaboration which we'll talk about
four lipsticks and obviously I love
makeup but you know as far as something
that I would want to own myself I feel
like I'm just so into scrubs and Max and
you know like hydration yeah sprays and
all this stuff and I just you know I'm
I'm obsessed with it and I'm constantly
spending my money on that and yes it's
just like oh then I would love to be
able to take things that I love from
different things and combine them into
something that you know because I feel
like I'll buy a product and I'll be like
well I love this about it but I don't
like this yeah and I would love to be
able to have uh something that's new and
different and put that out there and so
that I love it and hopefully everyone
else let's take a listen whoever's out
there I want to start skincare line yeah
[Laughter]
I used the Frankie rose Pro contour
palette every day I'm not big on the
overly contoured look yeah there was
that phase there where everybody was
really excited and I I try to get into
it and I feel like it I have a various
my head is very small in a small face so
sometimes if I'm wearing too much makeup
it looks like not so cute so I use this
contour palette and basically what I do
is you can see when I open it I just
want to warn everyone these are my real
things out of my makeup bag that I've
been using for a while so I used this
one the most and sometimes I use a
little bit of this if I want to be a
little bit more or especially if like
like right now I'm spray tan
so I used a little bit of the darker one
and all I do is just right here
and sometimes I do a little bit up here
and then I always do my neck I feel like
the neck always gets so white and yeah
that is your channel Arjun yeah covers
my face will be tan and I'm like what
about I do it too it helps me um create
a stronger jawline yeah yeah if I
contour a little bit down here on-camera
highlighter sometimes on especially
since we film our show in the summer
it looks like sweaty yeah I've been a
little too greasy Pig yeah yeah so I try
to stay away from the highlight on my
cheeks swimmer filming yeah but I'll use
this in like my inner eye corners love
that and maybe like up here and then
these I know this is contour but
sometimes I use this as like a face on
my eyelid before I do i shadow same and
that's such a go to like if you don't
have our shadow you do yeah show me my
favorite part I know you don't like
highlighter while you're filming but I
know you have a highlighter I do I do so
my mom got me this I think like a couple
of years ago and it was one of those
things that I kind of forgot that I had
it for a while yeah and I love it it's
Bobbi Brown it's maybe they I don't like
these yeah no special edition Bobby
Brown shimmer brick compact in nude glow
it's got a gold a rose gold white
shimmer and then a bronze color and I
love using it you know sometimes I will
you know you have your little fan brush
yeah
I'll swipe it around like the top too
and use it on my cheeks but sometimes I
honestly will use like this bronze as an
eyeshadow he's so pretty yeah these two
colors together okay I'll just show you
yes we need to see it so the rose gold
is gorgeous and then the gold is really
pretty too
and then you just said you don't wear
too much eye makeup but you do love
these palettes I yes yeah so I have like
I was saying small face small head small
eyelid area I have like more of a hooded
eye shape so it's hard for me sometimes
to do like a lot of those cool like the
cut crease look yeah I think since I
don't have a lot of space but I use
these again these are well well love it
as you can see but my so I'm just
wearing a little bit of this one in the
corner of my eyelid that looks beautiful
thanks I have green eyes so also these
types of colors like make them look
greener so I love them and then I'll use
this color creation
jam and mud to do instead of just like a
great black smokey I used those to
create what looks kind of like a sunset
smokey eye and that's kind of like my
favorite yeah I do that a lot that's
actually like my if I'm going out and I
want to look like a little and up yeah
that's what I usually go for and then
I'm wearing
Frankie rose collab with me in peeping
tom okay
the anticipation is killing me how did
you get started with this I've been
doing things here and there with Frankie
Rose for a little while and then they
approached me so funny is almost like
they read my mind so I really wanted to
do something I'm kind of in
collaboration with them and then they
approached me with this idea for instead
of like a regular holiday palette this
was a holiday palette that was news a
nudist palette that goes beyond just the
holidays this is something that's meant
to take you throughout the rest of the
year and so we're now in the beyond
portion of the holidays and beyond yeah
and we on we only have I think 200 units
left so this is basically kind of like
the last chance so you better go get it
right now so I picked these shades and I
named them so the free shades are bear
with me strip down and peeping tom so
and you have to buy them in the three
pack right yeah these are not sold
individually they only come in the pack
of three but the pack of three is only
$28 and I feel like I have lipsticks in
my bag that are like 28 dollars apiece
which was like I'm sorry I'm ashamed
ashamed to admit I'd spend that much
money on makeup since I'm a better
makeup junkie it's yeah thing I'm a
prodigy more so don't do what I do do as
I say I'll start with strip down with
the darkest of the three I guess I
should say on me it's a like a berry
color yeah
bear with me is more brownish yeah and
this one looks really good on me if I
have a tan or if I'm like going for like
a boho kind of
and then I saved the best for last
because this is my favorite and
everybody's been asking what this color
is by the way I wear it all the time it
really is my favorite and it's
peeping-tom
more of like a rose ma nude pink yeah
will show you the swatch it will give
you like a full yeah yeah so we've got
Chanel and she's probably our darkest
skin tone we've got Kristen who is our
second darkest Deidre who is our medium
tone
Miriam's rate is spray tanned and myself
who is just the palest person on earth
so yes these are the three colors and
again they're $20 for all three they
come in the set it's a box with my face
on it which is both amazingly cool and
also weird it's not so you can get this
the link is in my bio on Instagram and
Twitter they're also at select Planet
Beauty stores so yeah so go buy it
yeah cuz it's going up it's going quick
and there's only a little bit left so I
just wanted to make sure everybody gets
their hands on the last one
[Music]